[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con desde el 26
de abril hasta el 28 el foro abierto de
ciencia de américa latina y el caribe se
realiza una plataforma para debatir
sobre políticas eficaces con la meta de
alcanzar los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible de la agenda 2030 nos
acompaña desde montevideo lidia brito
directora de ciencias de la unesco para
américa latina y el caribe y creadora de
este foro gracias por acompañarnos
señora lydia y por estar con nosotros
que contendrá el foro sin la que inicia
este 26 de abril además de los temas de
ciencia
muchas gracias y gracias por la
invitación buenos días dice que el foro
es una plataforma es un espacio de
debate de conversación sobre el rol de
la ciencia para el desarrollo sostenible
con la pandemia comitentes a 9 vimos que
la ciencia ha conquistado quizás un
espacio público muy importante entonces
este silac del 2021 tiene esa
característica donde vamos a hablar del
nuevo rol de las ciencias para el
desarrollo sostenible ahora cuál ha sido
ese nuevo rol de la ciencia para para
que sea sostenible todo esto y además
generada por la crisis de la pandemia de
kobe 19 sin duda porque vimos que las
ciencias salvó vidas con esta pandemia
cada vez más presente también el
cotidiano
de los ciudadanos de las personas de la
gente entonces queremos una ciencia más
abierta y por eso la unesco defender la
ciencia abierta y estamos trabajando en
una recomendación suficiencia abierta
necesitamos más colaboración regional
internacional / la luz instigadores las
instituciones de investigación las
empresas necesitamos también de más
diplomacia científica para que se pueda
tener acuerdos que promuevan la ciencia
para todos y todas para que la ciencia
sea efectivamente para la gente sea
hecha también con la gente promoviendo
la ciencia ciudadana y más que nada el
tema central del foro quien se instruye
y llamando la atención en directo a la
ciencia y es un directo humano ahora a
libia hablan ustedes de la economía
digital cuáles son las oportunidades que
trae en medio de esta nueva normalidad
por la pandemia que ha sido todo un
desafío además para las sociedades
sin duda que hoy estamos viviendo un
mundo digital un mundo virtual y tenemos
que pensar como la economía digital
puede ser también para todos no el tema
es cómo garantizar que criamos y
desarrollamos en las personas el
potencial de ser en ciudadanos digitales
para que puedan efectivamente usar y
beneficiar de estas nuevas tecnologías
también tenemos que pensar que ya
principios éticos que tenemos que
respetar y que tenemos que estar
conscientes y por tanto cuando hablamos
de economía digital hablamos en las
varias dimensiones que esta economía
puede efectivamente servir a la región
para que el desarrollo el futuro
postpandemia sea más inclusivo sea más
armonioso que sea para todos no entonces
este es un gran reto que tenemos en las
discusiones de la silac cómo potenciar
las oportunidades de la economía digital
para que efectivamente nuestra región
pueda
de manera sostenible por último le
quería preguntar quiénes eran parte del
foro y dónde los podemos ver o escuchar
muchas gracias bien el foro el foro si
la puede decir listo virtualmente es
gratuito se tiene que registrar en la
plataforma
forum si la que vamos a tener altas
autoridades de la región y del mundo
tenemos bien el presidente de fórum va a
estar con nosotros en la primera plan
arias suficiencia inclusiva tenemos
ministros de toda la región y de la
región iberoamericana también así que
vamos a tener varias sesiones con ellos
nuestra directora general vaya a decir
la apertura del foro tenemos también
nuestros director general adjunto y de
la unesco participando en varias de las
sesiones tenemos sitios de empresas
tenemos académicos de renombre tenemos
jóvenes que están cambiando el mundo así
que en este momento están resfriados más
de 4500 personas del foro ha sido muy
satisfechos con la diversidad o con la
capacidad que tuvimos de hacer posible
si la que 121 en su persona la línea
y muy agradecidos a todos así desde
libia muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 gracias por su
tiempo ustedes también gracias continúan
con nosotros en nuestro canal
[Música]